you
okay here we go 82 players at start
let's see what we have we have a Carroll
Khan this is bullet standard the
mainline huh
how far down in theory are we gonna go
here okay this is a valuable tempo just
threaten a quick kill now they have to
back that Bishop up right 97 Queen here
let's go for a space advantage I could
also think about grabbing that pond and
maybe I should have I was threatening to
take on f7 and then e 6 and he takes
pawn here pretty dangerous I want a
Castle queenside Bishop d7 maybe they
gets did my C to pawn but would they
really go for that we're gonna find out
Castle queenside back my [ __ ] about
play C 4 and then move my dark square
bishop might have wanted to maybe I
should have considered doing that sooner
let's get rid of that night might be for
is a bit concerning all right let's get
him out of here they don't have the rook
playing that's in the corner let's take
here here pretty much no matter what
let's grab this pawn now Bishop can't
move this is oh this bishop is dead I
could have played maybe Knight into here
or a rook there actually mama d6 square
I have da cover with my bishop
let's take here and grab a check I'm
gonna take my knight just any move
they're not gonna couldn't finish they
were down a time Heiser
okay we got 2 is a lot of people with
twos let's try I guess Benko gambit
stuff then alright let's go here when to
take on that be 5 square and I don't
know maybe only after the bishop moves
okay they're giving the pawn back just
to shut down a file let's pin this
Knight and then play my knight in to d7
reroute to get to that b6 square put
pressure on their Bishop maybe c4 Bishop
back and on f4 maybe this okay so this
diagonal is opened up I could give a
check on F
or let's invest some material pressure
on b2 I've pressure on the night as well
difficult to develop their queenside
okay they're dropping that night I'm on
the rook I can also drop back and give a
check my knight can arrive and hit that
e4 square they're gonna resign let's get
that in they're not gonna block with the
bishop right i money for its land a4 get
some material actually on rook there I
have a fork and they resigned back to
tournament four is four four four three
okay watch out for the shark there's a
shark in here 21:18 alright let's go
with Scandinavian but okay turned
caro-kann ich let's line my bishop up
and keep my Queen here I guess
okay I'm lining some tricky stuff up
right now oh okay
should probably target h2 i just netted
a piece right there
i want to get rid of their night let's
go a little wild you can't take my
bishop clean the pawns in a pin I'll
take now I could have taken h2o but I'm
up a piece and I could also think about
continuing to push Oh grab a tempo
against my queen again okay I have to be
careful a little bit with my king queen
g5 a little bit concerning king f7
though should be fine expecting rook c1
grabbing a tempo first rook to g8 soon
or work to c1 okay whew if pressure on
this square I got a defend I don't like
this Knight here should shield any
checks along the F file let's go here
even if I had to give the exchange just
so I could tuck my king away 22 seconds
I'm on h2 I still have two minor pieces
I can't do this I got to get out of the
pin how they moved I didn't see that
they moved
I didn't hear rip to g1 okay they've
weakened their dark squares
Bishop here next and then some
devastating night move Queen here on f6
okay this is collapsing Queen check and
then Knight forks here probably no
matter what let's come back let's do
that okay this is me I was just doing
time burning stuff with rook takes g2
there back to tournament nine eight
eight eight someone preserved Bigfoot
I'll just call them Bigfoot berserk
they're twenty five minutes remaining
nine eight eight eight six there are
ninety nine players at this point the
shark I was talking about this guy
earlier okay let's go with this stuff
here nice and solid okay they're gonna
play e4 it's a good pre move doesn't
sneak in there okay we're gonna play in
the Queen side now I have a light square
bishop that hopefully will be a good
defender this runs into c5 gonna do this
anyway so now I'm winning some material
okay I grabbed that and let's break over
here open up the B file and maybe target
I'm gonna grab that pawn because it
gives me the g5 square and maybe I could
play f6 let's grab another pawn play my
queen here she could get kicked around
let's let's break on this side of the
board
take with my rook in case my queen gets
diverted from defense of this pawn it's
double up I could take in here on Bishop
h3 mmm let's get over here so Bishop
there isn't happening with check slight
time edge here pawn push next break in
the center okay I want my knight to be
in a better position just take like this
defending I'm opening the G file as well
pawn push is a threat f4 let's get on
with that
[Music]
give this check keep pushing I have this
square covered I have a check here as
well let's keep pushing I have my knight
defended my Knights are inching closer
Knight g4 ok I have to give up there
light square bishop I have a check that
can't be right can it clean check I have
covered let's do this I have the checks
covered I'm hitting that bishop again
clean trade just pile up hit the rook I
have a good time edge here no matter
what they're down on time back to
tournament 13 12 12 9 ok 22 minutes it's
still a young young tournament big foot
this is the leader I gotta get this guy
he's got a 5 point lead someone really
has to knock him off ok let's let's go
with this why not
Knight g4 I should have secured that ok
we're gonna go after their King now
Queen d2 h4 h5 caveman-style caveman
attack let's do this queenside castle
soon ok another night oh I'm dropping
that pun ahh that was bad I'm dropping
this pawn as well what am i doing let's
get rid of their night ok
maybe get my knight here now they should
do pawn push it's strong ok I think they
missed that oh no I'm getting this my
knight is a monster all of a sudden no
its castle and defend Queen c4 I have
good light square control let's take
this pawn on the rook at the end I
really dodged a bullet I really dodged a
bullet there they had Queen h4 so
there's really nice control now over
this position I should have played a 4
well they moved I didn't realize that
they moved take with my king because I'm
gonna get my a pawn working he's passed
I don't care about my age upon the a
pawn is more
the refs are gonna have to leave the D
file soon my king is in a really good
spot Forks they missed that they might
resign they resigned back determined
that's a big win he was the leader and
now he's doesn't have streak
he's not on streak anymore 18 17 16
still 20 minutes remain
okay standing for amadon all right
here's a big gun let's go with the
Sicilian okay and have it a little
exchange here all right I'm gonna take
I'm gonna decline that I don't know that
this is a good uh with the isolated pond
here I'm on this guy I'm not threatening
to take just yet I wonder I have a good
control I have control over the D file
all right excuse me the d5 square I'll
wait for them to kick my night before I
go to d4 d5 let's go here now actually I
changed my mind
whoa I missed that I don't want to take
I shouldn't have played h6 they're still
going there
what you serious I go for perpetual or
what nah man don't go for perpetual go
for more okay there you go um maybe
maybe I'm in trouble
maybe I'm definitely in trouble could I
do this and get away with it we're gonna
find out
oh I've burned so much time so much time
I want I wanted to go to this should be
fine I have things covered Wow oh I
don't have any time let me throw in a
fast fast move Bishop check Bishop there
13 seconds I've ordered the attack
thwarted what a beautiful word to say
my knight on h7 is still pinned
let's keep pressure on g2 you got to go
faster not going faster
oh boy that's a dangerous night oh I
just dropped a piece didn't I
I don't have time to look if I even drop
the piece uh
this is very scary that night's gonna
kill me oh boy Oh
house this time I'm down on time no
they're down on time oh I'm sorry if I
got loud I know I know I got loud I
thought I lost that time as clicky like
crazy with my mouse of course what else
are you clicking with not your moves on
the chess board the move sometimes just
don't click they don't work out too well
all right let's build a Center and let's
let's not play h6 and then crawl up into
a ball in fear okay here we go
here we go the four pawns attack on the
queenside watch out for it that's
probably opposite their queen and rook
all right c4 at some point you're gonna
release the tension the center and kick
my knight around grab some space okay
they went into the think tank there for
a minute let's get opposite their queen
again make them feel maybe uncomfortable
let's break on c4 open up the D file on
any take on c4 taking like this I could
shut down that bishop but I don't know
that I want to do that okay it's opening
up to my benefit d3 is collapsing okay
and now I can cash out here grab some
material and I have a very dangerous
dangerous pawn here on b4 hit that Queen
again here probably no matter what
you're not going to take my truck
hopefully all right let's get rid of
their dark square bishop maybe one of
their better pieces in this position
okay they don't have much time take my
rook
let's take here replace that rook with a
knight
and anything take my night and I have
any time back to tournament 24 22 22 21
about the halfway point here all right
let's try d4 and e4 no matter what that
was so bad that was so bad okay
anything but that move efore would have
been fine you could play it as a gambit
okay where's they're not gonna go I have
a space advantage I go one step so I
could Castle queenside and let's throw
this H pawn into the mix oh I got to be
careful i light squares let's just do
this to kick the bishop off of this
diagonal they're gonna take with their F
pawn yeah that's a strong move I'm gonna
have to give up my clean soon to feel it
he could feel it
there she goes the beautiful attack well
legs well executed right there well
executed alright they're gonna invest
some material back I have zero attack I
have a tricky Knight that's all I have
- tricky Knights is all I have is
compensation let's see if they get work
some magic work some magic would you
[Music]
where's the magic I don't see a magic it
the Queen I have a four second lead for
second time edge one move threats
amazing watch out for the one move
threats okay I think you give a check on
the seventh I still have the tricky
night around I guess we're gonna go here
and hope for the best my Knights a good
defender it should be pretty safe for my
king let's grab upon three seconds stop
back here maybe insert some checks
let's get that clean out here hit the
rope
maybe give a check over here come back
tricky nights tricky nights there's a
fork finally he did something dangerous
back to tournament barely was all I was
playing for as soon as I had to give up
my queen oh man thank goodness for a
knight always keeps you guessing doesn't
he you cannot rely upon any color
complex with the bishop you can okay
note to self hang on your queen would
you she's important she's very important
it'd be nice if you could win a game
objectively instead of playing with the
clock all the time really I mean come on
what's the story here let's pile up on
the pin piece let's go G for most
committal move around what about that
move okay that would have been nice
alright let's kick this night away
they're gonna post up I don't want to
take let's go here my bishops gonna get
crunched I thought I thought at least
let's get back on this diagonal very
weak and diagonal very weakened okay
these bishops are very dangerous how
about that what a sight double isolated
G pawns beautiful double isolated G
pawns everybody wants them everybody
let's take here now you're gonna try and
make me over here let's go here rook to
h4 h5 I have stuff covered don't I h 1 g
2 it's scary but i should be able to
work with it ok my rook is having that
responsibility now i might want to give
up some material just to get the queen's
off the board it's back up
don't fall for me go on whatever you do
this time edge o let's grab this pawn
now the rooks are getting active I'm
crawling up into a ball I have pressure
on F something f7 19 seconds this is
ugly chess if you didn't realize very
ugly chests
I'm gonna end up in a fork soon rook F
to my rook on h4 amazing stuff amazing I
love that rook on h4 brilliant he's a
brilliant piece nine seconds we get a
Queen trade don't I just fell from 81
they didn't get time to do it Queen
Queen h1 oh my goodness Queen h1 3432
Kingslayer let's play e4 and let's play
where I don't attack cuz clearly it's
not working out no I insist I insist
even if the attacks don't work still try
you never know you just never know Queen
h1 ball game didn't have time or maybe
was trying to move it and it just wasn't
working he was having mouse issues okay
we have an open G file let's back up
open the a file for my rook King h1 rook
g1 let's back up king h1 rook g1 okay
here we go anyone he's gonna take there
any moment any moment it's never
happening back
it'll happen the one time I don't pre
move it okay we're gonna have this
alright let's get rid of their bishop
who's trying to defend here now they
take it there we go Knight d5 you really
want to get there I'm gonna end up in a
fork if I'm not careful look I have h3
covered maybe skewer town okay I
shouldn't I shouldn't be too scared
about this yeah I should I was gonna end
up in another for quit tonight h3 all
right let's put pressure here I'd love
to see this move Bishop here is a killer
all right that's got to be scary right I
want to get this move in
let's take upon 95 next the Knights in a
pin not anymore
just move anywhere anywhere fast
back up night f4 to here Oh all the more
appealing night g6 night spend he's hit
a million times f4 on King here g5 is
collapsing
let's take here oh they should have
taken back ok
just anything just move faster make it
one threat move the bishop and then give
a night check they don't have any time
back to tournament what did I do
view tournament that's where I want to
be 38 36 this guy's a two point lead but
he's not on streak 38 36 33 26 still
tight pack still 10 minutes remain whoo
okay there's a hundred and eleven people
who are in this one 111 players efore
again okay let's develop and play I
guess d5 next not quiet let's just break
a pin
let's grab some space right here I take
and I'm winning material okay they
missed that combination so I'm off a
piece here let's convert it quickly
oh I'm just down a piece now not down a
piece they could get that Bishop back
that's ok let's launch a jeep on right
watch that Jeep on mmm now I have
something to bite out
I could play g4 g5
let's take with the pond if I take with
the night their Bishop is helped out
getting into that f6 f6 square quickly
so I'm looking at h4 g5 this next couple
moves are super important for black to
find good moves I have this square
covered enough for right now g5 next if
the G file or H file opens up big
trouble that's a piece f7 is hit it's
another piece
let's just cash out give investment
material that's me back to tournament
40:38 I have a lead it's a small one 40
38 37 mm-hmm not a fan of going berserk
it's not necessary I only like those I
only like making those decisions towards
the end depending on how are doing uh in
the tournament all right let's put
pressure on b7 okay that have to go back
well I don't know about half due but
they didn't want a week in their Queen
side I guess so we have a exchange Cairo
where they're LightSquared Bishop is not
it's not a mouse slip I want to do that
let's stop there minority attack let's
go over here focus on this square
they're going to take my bishop
they are so now I have play against the
h7 pawn let's do this Bishop back Queen
c2 or 95 and on Knight takes pawn takes
removing the defender I should have done
this right away
let's do right now so if my Knights ever
captured I'm going to take with my pawn
I also have IDs of g4g for g5 so right
now if they're taking I'm taking like
this removing the defender of h7 g for
g5 looking to put this rook to use there
should be a fine home for my king 20
seconds for team black let's get on with
it and I'm just gonna do a push next 15
seconds I could insist on removing the
night with f4 and g5 but okay that's
dropping this pawn and this squares
collapsing I have every piece hitting it
so this should be made very very soon
even do King here and then rook to h1
next they resigned back to tournament 44
41 I have a three point lead six minutes
remain 44 41 3931 okay the Kingslayer
again
let's go with Knight f6 I guess
nimzo-indian okay classical no there's
nothing with this isn't I'm not winning
upon here the knight is pinned it's one
of the drawbacks with Queen c2 she's not
defending the deep the D file anymore
so I'm looking to expand let's keep this
here I don't want to help there bishop
let's open it up okay now let's take and
then take with my knight let's insert a
check first and then take here I was
worried about ending up in a pin with
queenside castle so they should be very
very good their King is in the center my
Brook is opposite their king I don't
know if I'll even be concerned about
this pawn if bishop here let's continue
to develop night here I don't even know
what that move does I guess it opens up
a file alright let's remove the knight
h2 it's a queen let's play Queen here
it's just a very active pawn push could
be sneaky at some point I'm not even
sure what this move does drops upon okay
this is my plan Queen here Bishop here
the bishop could defend though let's
let's regroup not the best square I'm
kind of in a pin here let's hang on to
that pond I have my knight defending my
rook okay it's that bishop doing okay
let's do this
this is finally working with the g2 idea
made on g2 have to give up the Queen or
are they going to resign they're
thinking about it it's a time when at
least it should be Knight F okay they
resigned back to tournament 48 I have a
5 point lead for ta 4341 fight club okay
[Music]
let's let's still go with Knight to f6
and we'll stick with the nihms out here
for another game at least it's try and
finish strong here knight c6 because
clearly during the tournament it hasn't
been strong that Queen h1 move I was I
was ready to scream I was definitely
ready to scream ok let's let's do this
support it with my knight on g6 so this
should be this should be very good
let's move my knight I want to take on
h4 with my queen
just to tempted to tempted to take that
and now I still need to get oh they
didn't take that I'm on the rook ok
let's just take their night so I'll have
to worry about Knight their stuff Knight
b5 nightly they are stuff my bishops
going to enter let's take here with
check first and now the Queen's pinned
less than three minutes remain
Bishop's in trouble King up and then
wrote to f8 this should be mate next
that's me back to term inch 52:42 I have
a seven-point lead 2 minutes 30 seconds
52 45 45
that's probably unless something crazy
happens that's maybe close to sealing it
Hamadan could still catch me possibly
with because he might still be in a game
and ready to he could maybe win and they
get another game in so if I win this one
I think I have it and it's not looking
pretty
this actually might not be so bad I have
the G file we're gonna make this one
work
ugly pawn structure incoming okay let's
do this they're gonna take my knight
okay stop the I have the bishop pair I
have active pieces here let's just take
their and stop Knight g4 stuff
it's coming all the way back king d2
pressure on their bishop let's throw
some punches double up okay let's not
trap it's not threatening to trap
anything back up they're doing well in
the clock here maybe I could come back
over let's break these guys up that
wasn't a good idea
hey maybe it was let's get one rook off
I was fearing the doubling coming over
here now my king could defend my bishops
looking pretty good I have this Knight
under control this night could have been
taken in any one of two ways let's try
it again let's try it again nope you
don't really get too many chances do you
okay I'm on the knight next time take
him if he's free with any one of your
two pieces any one of those two let's
run with this pond he has passed after
all and now my bishop is brought to life
I'm dropping this but I have a scary
h-bond super scary no mates here are
there let's insert this check not quite
I'm gonna give a check next and then
promote a width check see if we could
weave a mate that's check mate next they
resigned back to tournament that's going
to seal it and it was very important
that I did do that fifty six fifty three
forty five it's important that I got
that win and I'm up by a point this is
the tournament gonna end hopefully he's
not paired up and ready to win any
second no buzzy no buzzer-beaters please
what do we have finally a little bit too
close there man
okay final standings fifty six fifty
three forty five forty three forty all
right good games oh I got way too lucky
in too many games Queen each one that
would have really set me off there I
would have asked
and then probably laughed into like the
next game okay let's see the final
standings there we go
a hundred and twenty to end up taking
part in this and here was everyone else
page two three four etc 51 through 60 61
through 70 and that's everyone all right
again to the 122 of you who took part in
this one Gigi's
you